[MUSIC]
Think back to the last time
you were in a hospital.
What do you see?
Maybe you walked through clear glass
doors into a gleaming white lobby.
You see doctors in white coats,
stethoscopes draped around their necks.
You see nurses in blue scrubs,
something a little bit like this.
Maybe you haven't actually been in
a hospital in a little while, but
you've watched a lot of Grey's Anatomy and
House.
And so, you can just picture
those same doctors and
nurses floating off in corners of
the hospital solving medical mysteries.
Well, I've spent the last five years
working in and with hospitals.
And that's not what I see.
In fact, every time I would walk into
a new hospital, I would go to the door and
put my hand out for the handle and
I would hesitate before I opened.
Do I really want to go inside?
Hospitals have a problem, and
this problem is killing us.
99,000, 99,000 people
every year are killed by this
problem in the United States.
1 in 20,
1 in 20 patients who steps foot into
a hospital would be
affected by this problem.
What is this problem?
Do you know?
It's not common knowledge, so
there is a good chance that you don't.
Hospital-acquired infections.
Hospital-acquired infections
are infections that a person did not have
prior to entering the hospital in which
they would not have otherwise contracted
had they not been in hospital.
They're almost entirely preventable.
And yet, in 2020, they will kill
99,000 people in the United States.
That's 1 person every 5 minutes.
That's two times the number
of people who would be killed
in car accidents this year.
That's three times the number of
people who will be killed by guns
in the United States in 2020.
How can this happen?
Well, there is a system that
is broken in the hospital and
I'm going to show you what that is.
So let's think again
about our hospital here.
We walk inside, and we look around, and
there is something that we cannot see.
And it's everywhere in the hospital.
Germs.
But these aren't you normal germs, these
are not the germs that you'll find down at
Starbucks or
at your local office building.
These germs are what are called superbugs.
These superbugs go by many names.
MRSA, Clostridium difficile or C diff,
Candida auris, CRE, VRE,
and they are deadly.
To put this in perspective for
you, everybody now knows about
this 2019 novel Coronavirus.
Well, if you catch the Coronavirus,
you have a 2% chance of dying.
If you catch MRSA or
C diff or Candida auris or
one of these other super bugs,
you have up to a 30% chance of dying.
These superbugs are also widespread.
So, as of today, March 3rd, 2020,
approximately 90,000 people have
been infected with the Coronavirus.
And that's worldwide.
But just this year and just in the United
States, 1.7 million people will be
infected with one of these superbugs that
leads to hospital-acquired infection.
So you don't need to get into a plane and
fly off to Wuhan.
Or you don't need to get into a cruise
ship that's stuck off the coast of Japan
to be exposed to some the world's
most deadliest germs.
All you have to do is get into a car and
drive down to your local hospital.
So let's come back again
to our hospital here.
It's a beautiful hospital.
And we walk inside.
There's something that we don't
see when we're in this hospital.
What we don't see is the people who are
dedicated to cleaning up the superbugs.
I'm going to call these
people our superheroes.
And who are these superheroes?
Are they our doctors or our nurses or
hospital administrators?
No, our superheroes
are the environmental services staff.
They are the janitors and
the housekeepers of the hospital.
So I'm going to tell you a story
about one of these superheroes.
Her name is Marie.
So Marie is a mother of four children.
She works three jobs,
part time jobs at minimum wage
just to barely make ends meet.
She tells herself she can keep it
all together but she's exhausted.
She's probably slept on average
about four hours every night for
the past, God knows how many weeks.
But she's not just exhausted
from the lack of sleep.
She's exhausted from the heroic
job that she does in the hospital.
So let's take a minute to consider
everything that Marie needs to do,
every time she walks into a new
hospital patient room to clean it.
And she has to do this over and
over again throughout the day.
So Marie walks into this hospital room,
she has to strip the linens from the bed.
She then has to inspect the mattress,
make sure that there are no punctures or
holes or other issues of the mattress,
that's very important.
She then has to remake
the bed with fresh linens.
She then has to disinfect every single
surface within that hospital room.
So everything from the light switches,
the doorknobs, the bedside table,
the overhead table, the bed rails.
She has to disinfect pull cords, all of
the medical equipment, any chairs and
their arm rails.
She then has to go into the bathroom, and
she has to disinfect the sink, the faucet,
the drain, the toilet,
the guard rails on the side of the toilet.
She then has to disinfect the pool
cords in there and then disinfect and
mop the floor in the patient room and
in the bathroom.
How much time do you think we should
give superhero, Marie, to do this job?
I'll give you a hint.
So in the hotel industry,
housekeepers are given on average 30
minutes to turn a room in between guests.
But hotels are not
a critical care environment.
Hotels don't have patience.
In hospitals, Marie is only given 10
minutes, just 10 minutes to change
this patient room and do all those
critical things that need to be done.
10 minutes.
Just imagine the next time you go into
a hotel, do you think that the housekeeper
only took 10 minutes in between cleaning
the room between you and the prior guest?
Now, imagine that that prior guest
had a deadly colon infection.
I mean, those rooms are not clean.
It's really disgusting.
So, there's something else that
you don't see about Marie, and
that is that she is not respected in
this hospital, and neither is her job.
Just yesterday she was
yelled at by a nurse for
not turning an operating room
quickly enough, even though she knew
that moving any faster would
seriously compromise patient safety.
Marie also has not been given
the right tools for her job.
She's been given disinfectants that are
ineffective, they're the cheapest possible
disinfectants and they don't work against
the superbugs that we're concerned about.
She's given mops and wipes that come
back from the laundry contaminated.
She just reintroduces whatever
she took out yesterday
back into the hospital environment.
Marie was also never trained properly.
The prevalent feeling among
hospital administrators is,
why would we invest in training people for
this role?
It's easy, anybody can do it,
its not important.
All of these things.
The lack of a proper paycheck, the lack of
respect, the lack of tools and the lack
of training and the lack of enough
staff to actually do this job right.
Has contributed to an environment
where Murray just hates this job.
How could she not, how can you blame her?
All of these factors are within
the hospital's control and yet
nothing is done about this.
And in fact, the very first
place that most hospitals look
when they want to trim their budget, is
at the environmental services department.
So where does this leave us?
Okay, on the one hand, we have our
superbugs that are extremely deadly,
on the other hand,
we have our superheroes.
And we've created a situation
where we have tied these
hands of our superheroes
behind their backs.
We have made it impossible for
them to do their job.
It's no wonder that the superbugs
are winning in this battle versus
the superheroes.
All of this right now is abstract.
This isn't real, but
the consequences of this are real.
So let me show you what you can see.
This is Emma Grace Bru.
Emma contracted a MRSA infection when she
was a newborn at a hospital in Louisiana.
She had a twin brother, her twin
brother also contracted an infection.
He died when he was 14 days old.
Emma lived on, she had permanent damage
to her legs, her lungs and her heart.
She was in and out of the hospital for
the first few years of her life.
When she was three and
a half she went back into the hospital for
yet another surgery to her leg.
This time when she was in the hospital,
she contracted pneumonia.
The doctors told her parents that because
the MRSA had so devastated her immune
system when she was a newborn,
there was probably nothing they could do.
And in fact, Emma die just days
shy of her fourth birthday.
And this is what happens
every five minutes.
But there is hope.
There is something that we can do.
So for the past five years,
I've been working on a company that
addresses some of these issues.
And I know what you're thinking.
We're sitting here in Silicon Valley,
there must be some sort of high
tech solution to this problem.
But what I love about the solution
is that it can be low tech.
So my company,
we developed a platform of tools and
training that we could actually plug into
a hospital to help address those two
issues out of the five
that I mentioned earlier.
And just by addressing those two issues,
we're able to reduce infections by over
30% in all the hospitals
that we worked with.
But I'm not here to talk about my company.
I'm here to talk about the three things
that I think all of us in this room
can do to actually make a difference and
help solve this problem.
So what are those three things?
The first thing is awareness.
That's what we're doing here right now.
We need to talk about this issue.
We need to shine a light on it.
Hospitals have a vested interest
in keeping this issue in the dark.
And it's up to all of us to bring it out
of the shadows into the light of day.
The second thing we need to do.
We need to get hospitals to change how
they deal with their environmental
services department.
We need them to fix these issues and
take them seriously and
then we need to hold them accountable for
doing that.
So how can you hold
a hospital accountable?
There are now great resources online.
Hospital Compare is one of the best.
It's put together by the government, and
you can actually go onto this website and
you can compare your local
hospital versus regional and
national benchmarks and see how it
stacks up in terms of infection rates.
We all have to remember that we are
consumers of healthcare as patients and
as the loved ones of patients.
We need to send a message to hospitals,
that as customers, we can take
our business elsewhere if they don't
shape up and fix this infection issue.
And the third thing we need
to do comes down to respect.
So, I mentioned that my company
has a training component to it.
One of our best trainers who works with
the environmental services staff in
the hospital told me a story that
totally changed my perspective on this.
And so, he told me that when
he would go into the hospital,
he was having a lot of trouble.
He felt like he wasn't getting
through to these environmental
services staff to the janitors and
the housekeepers.
And he did one simple thing at the
beginning of each training session that
totally changed the mindset
in that room and
shifted how he interacted with
the housekeepers in the training sessions.
He started each session by saying, purpose
over paycheck, purpose over paycheck.
And just those three things
totally changed the dynamic.
And I think what he did was
he was showing respect.
He was showing respect for
the environmental services workers.
And showing them that they have a purpose
in this job and it is important.
And so, I think the next time all of
you are in the hospital, you should say
thank you when you see the janitor or
the housekeeper in that hospital.
Show them the respect they deserve and
show them that you
understand the incredibly important role
that they have in keeping patients safe.
Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> [MUSIC].